là cái chân của tôi trước khi mà tôi sinh em bé
mà sau khi mà tôi sinh em bé
thì cái chân của tôi nó như thế này các bà đây
mặc dù là nó
kiểu như là nó không được mịn màng như người ta
nhưng mà so với cái hồi trước đây là
nó đỡ rất là nhiều luôn
trước đây là bị viêm nang lông
cái lông cái lông ấy xong rồi
thật Ra là nó nó bị cuộn ở bên trong
cái nó giống như là của cái mụn nhân ấy
lúc mà mình nặn Ra á thì nó nặn Ra được cái bã đấy
xong rồi cái lông nó bị quạt ở bên trong á
nó xoăn tít lại xong rồi nó không có dài lắm à
nó nó nó làm Cho mình kiểu
khá là mất tự tin
ngày xưa tôi chẳng bao giờ mặc váy đâu các bà ạ
không bao giờ tôi mặc váy nhá
bởi vì là nó kiểu không tự tin lắm
để mãi sau này khi mà sinh em bé xong thì nó mới khỏi
biết là SAO mà khỏi không
cái việc mà mình bị viêm nang lông
ấy là nó do mình bị thiếu
vitamin a này
C này e này k này
thiếu những cái
vitamin đấy nó sẽ làm Cho cái
nang lông của mình nó bị dày sừng
nó bị dày sừng và nó cứ mùa đông mà lúc mà thay quần á
mà nhất là mặc cái quần tất ấy mà
nó trắng xóa như là Tuyết luôn ấy
bởi vì rất là nhiều cái tế bào chết bị bong Ra
thì sau khi mà mình sinh em bé xong á thì mình bổ sung
vitamin rất là đầy đủ
ngày trước thì cũng có nhưng mà tận tịch
lúc thì bổ sung lúc thì không
nhưng mà lúc mà mình
mang Thai mà mình có em bé thì mình bổ sung rất là đều
2 nữa là mình
mình bôi thêm cái này
cái dày sừng nang lông á là các bà biết SAO hông
là bây giờ mình phải làm bạt sừng đi
làm bạt đi bạt đi cái lớp sừng nó đang rất là dày ấy
ấy để để giải thoát được cái lông cái lông ở bên dưới á
thì là nó mới thoáng và nó khỏe thì nó mới khỏi được
một tuần mình à
sau khi mà uống vitamin thì nó sẽ phải uống dài một chút
uống vitamin thì chưa thể nào mà thấy ngay được
nhưng mà khi mà uống vitamin được khoảng một 2 tháng
kết hợp với bôi cái này ấy
thì chỉ cần sau khoảng một đến 2 tuần là các bà sẽ thấy là
cái lỗ chân lông của mình nó được cải thiện rất là nhiều
cái chân nó sẽ mịn màng hơn nhá
cái da và cái thâm của mình nó cũng sẽ đơ đi rất nhiều trong
này trong cái thành phần của nó có axit salicylic
nó là một cái chất bong Ra bạt sừng
nó giúp bạt đi ấy
với cái nồng độ Cao ấy thì nó sẽ bong Ra bạt sừng
với cái nồng độ thấp ấy thì nó sẽ có cái tác dụng giữ ẩm
ngoài Ra thì nó có thêm cả
vitamin C và một số những cái khác để giúp Cho cái việc là
à bong Ra bạt sừng và
cải thiện cái vấn đề viêm nang lông rất là tốt nên là
ừm mình ờ ngoài Ra nhá nó có rất là hay
nó có thêm cả lactobacilus
nó là một cái lợi khuẩn nó sống ở trên da của mình ấy
khi mà nó sống ở trên da của mình nó sẽ ngăn ngừa
những cái con VI khuẩn có hại khác
nó đánh đuổi những cái con VI khuẩn có hại khác nó xâm nhập
ấy và nó sẽ giúp Cho cái cái vùng da của mình nó được khỏe
nó tiết Ra những cái chất để nó bảo vệ cái vùng da
đấy của mình kết hợp với lại vitamin C và rồi platinon
tức là nó làm lành cái tổn thương của cái da
sau khi mà nó được bạt sừng xong thì nó sẽ làm lành và
và nó giúp cái da nó khỏe hơn ấy